you are the dictionary definition of a
delight you really are so can I give you
the compliment I was going to give you
before I was rudely interrupted by
every okay go ahead I'm getting a note
now Conan take a shower you stink Jesus
no I was going to say when you guys
asked me to come back I was so touched
so honored to come be a second time
arrival and I couldn't wait because you
from the first one of the first talk
shows I ever did you were so look it's
scary to do that sort of thing when
you're new and you were so amazing and
you made me you made me laugh so hard
and I told I I told someone after
someone on my team I said he's one of
those that saves you I'm like he's a
saver so if you start to maybe you're
missing you dive in and No One Ever
Knows and you save the day and you say
something funny or you do something that
no one realizes there was a lag and that
is such a nice thing and so coming here
is like a part I couldn't wait well
that's very sweet of you to say but you
know what no one needs less saving than
qu I'll tell you that right now there
are people that in my life whove who've
needed saving and I do like to help
people who uh who need help in that
moment but good God you do not need any
help you're very sweet this is such a
fun room also my fiance sent a video to
you and he wants you to watch it cuz
he's a big fan oh I was going to have
him come he say once he says hi and he's
just a big fan well have we met do we
know each other think you guys you he's
an amazing actor I'm familiar with both
your work yeah I mean I would like to we
got to hang sometime um oh suddenly
you're busy aren't you did you guys see
that we should hang sometime and you
know what I've never seen the light go
out of someone's eyes so quickly it's
like I asked you for a kidney no did you
we have that on tape oh my God please
get the video you will see a soul leave
a
body
can I don't I can't understand why
someone with a 9-month-old and 19 dogs
would want month today we'll see 10 mon
like you know her birthday I I I don't I
don't I Googled it before I walked in
cuz I knew you guys would ask I got to
Google my child's name what's her name
well tell your husband I would love to
your fiance I would love to hang with
him or meet him or whatever so ni he
would love to meet you too um he loves
you well uh roleplay really good and
it's on it's on Prime video I'm so happy
for you you uh yeah I am thinking about
the first time I went over and taped a
bit over on the big Bank set you guys
were all there and I because I was next
door and I remember thinking this is
like the number one show on television
and you could expect a set like that to
be tense and weird and you were the N it
was just a group of nice people yeah and
I thought something's very wrong here
you're supicious I went back to my set
and created the the sort of creepy
tension that I think you need for really
good but worked out well for you yeah KY
uh we absolutely adore you come back
here anytime this is a this was like a
joy for me today I couldn't wait to get
here and I can't wait to hang out with
you when you're head out now it's going
to take no it's going to take four miles
for me to walk to get to my car so I got
to head out now I need a Gatorade can
you send me with a sandwich yes we'll
send youand Long Walk thank you